hi mystery Recaps here today I'm going
to explain an American Horror Anthology
film called nightmare Cinema spoilers
ahead watch out ants take care
at the start of the movie a girl named
Samantha is walking down the streets at
night as she reaches a theater named of
the Rialto she notices that it is
showing the movie the thing in the woods
with her name below it taken aback she
decides to enter the theater and watch
the movie soon Samantha sees a bloodied
version of herself running away from
someone in the woods that someone is
revealed to be the welder a giant
butcher with a metal mask over his face
as Samantha runs for her life she trips
over a dead corpse which almost gives
her a heart attack fortunately her
boyfriend Jason arrives at the scene and
pulls her aside they then escape from
the place before the welder can get to
them after hours of running they finally
reach the road and see a vehicle
approaching them Jason immediately asks
for a lift and luckily it turns out to
be a police car a chubby looking cop
emerges and asks the couple why the girl
is covered in blood when Jason explains
everything he finally agrees to give
them a lift but before they can leave
the welder arrives in front of them the
cop gets out of the car and shoots at
the giant multiple times causing him to
drop to the floor however when he
proceeds to the car he accidentally
trips and shoots himself blowing his
brains out hmm smoke to bacon the welder
also gets up and starts chasing after
the couple in the next scene they arrive
at one of their friends Mike's house the
latter is confused seeing their
condition so Samantha explains
everything right then the welder arrives
outside and throws a hammer knocking
Mike to the ground when the welder tries
to enter inside Jason blocks the door
and takes the shotgun off the wall to
shoot him his attempts fail as the
welder breaks the door and enters the
house before stabbing Mike with a weapon
Jason shoots him but the welder uses
Mike as a shield and manages to save
himself when one of the bullets hits
Mike's head it bursts into pieces
splattering blood everywhere terrified
of what she just saw Samantha quickly
runs off to the basement following that
Jason starts fighting the Wilder trying
to use a knife against him however the
welder manages to stab him with it he is
then burned to death with a flaming tool
Samantha enters the basement at the same
time and yells in Terror at finding
mutilated corpses inside hearing her
boyfriend's last scream she accepts her
fate and decides to die fighting rather
than running she emerges from the
basement intending to kill the welder
and attacks him surprisingly enough she
overpowers him easily seconds before the
welder is killed his mask comes off as
it turns out the Killer is none other
than Samantha's friend Fred upon being
asked what's going on Fred says me and
scoob and the Gang always took the masks
off I wanted to wear one but actually
Fred urges her to remember what happened
last weekend the scene then shifts to a
week ago when Samantha and her friends
came to the woods for a night out they
get along well like normal people in
contrast to their situation a few
minutes ago things are going well until
suddenly they notice something big
falling from the sky Jason Takes it as
an opportunity to explore the woods and
add to their Adventure in the next hour
the group sets off to look for the
object that fell and finds that it is
made an impact on the ground a curious
Jason touches the mass causing a massive
number of spiders to emerge and Chase
the group everyone freaks out and tries
running away but strangely enough the
spiders pursue the group and enter their
bodies in a horrifying way it turns out
that after they take over a person's
body the insects are able to control
them soon everyone except Fred is taken
over by the spiders he somehow manages
to reach the cabin and decides that he
will kill his friends to stop the
spiders from spreading their Terror he
strategically suits himself with the
welding garment and starts killing all
of his friends back in the present
Samantha remembers everything including
how the spider got into her body just
when the realization hits her her skull
splits open revealing a spider hiding
inside Fred immediately grabs an ax and
hits her dead however when he walks out
of the house a large swarm of spiders
surrounds him in the following scene we
see Fred driving a car heading toward
the nearest city movements can be seen
inside his skull which makes it clear he
has also been possessed by the spiders
the next story is about a young couple
David and Anna one night they decide to
sneak into an empty theater to make love
this turns out to be the same theater
Samantha was at suddenly the screen
lights up and the couple is shown a
movie starring themselves Anna and David
are enjoying dinner at a restaurant as
they normally would but in this movie
Anna has a slight scar on her cheek
although David assures her she is pretty
she is insecure because of the scar to
help her confidence David offers to pay
for her plastic surgery wow he-180 on
that fast he talks about his mother who
has had several Works done to her face
and thinks that it is completely normal
clearly his mother hasn't seen Simon
Cowell lately the very next day Anna is
at the clinic where Dr leaner is
checking her scar the doctor confirms
that the plastic surgery will remove 95
percent of the scar and Anna happily
agrees to go through with the procedure
soon Anna is sedated and the doctor
works his magic on her while sleeping
she dreams of walking to David at her
wedding but when she reaches the altar
she finds Dr leaner and the nurses
carrying bloody tools afraid Anna wakes
up to see the nurse and David staring at
her face which is now bandaged because
of the medicine and as soon falls asleep
and David takes the opportunity to snap
pictures of her after Anna wakes up she
asks the nurse for a mirror but the
nurse rejects her request and does not
allow her to make any phone calls either
Anna thinks it is strange that she is
being isolated from the world and
decides to get out of her room to
investigate she finds the nurse's
computer and skims through it to find
some strange facts about the surgery
performed on her before she can look any
further the nurse returns Samantha
decides to flee but on her way she
notices someone asking for help from
inside a room she goes in and is
horrified to find a woman whose eyes and
nose have been surgically cut out making
her look inhumane this is the kind of
thing you accidentally see on TV as a
kid and it's scarsy for Life afraid Anna
tries to run away but gets noticed by
the nurse she manages to knock the nurse
out and get into the elevator but when
it stops the doctor is waiting for her
outside they forcefully sedate her and
bring her back to the operating table to
perform yet another surgery on her in
the next scene we see Anna waking up
beside David she takes off her bandages
and tries to look at herself in the
mirror and to her horror she no longer
looks anything like herself her facial
structures changed she has several scars
on it and her nose has been half removed
Samantha screams out loud while David's
mother comes into the room and
compliments her looks the scene abruptly
changes back to the theater where Anna
is now alone she walks around and bumps
into the projectionist who explains to
her that the movie is actually about her
worst nightmare the scene ends as
Samantha screams out loud the third
story in the series also starts outside
the same theater a Church's father named
Benedict enters the theater upon seeing
his name displayed outside he is asked
to sit down and shown a movie about his
church then we are introduced to a
possessed boy named Peter standing on
the church's roof he acts erratic and
threatens to jump a nun frantically
approaches Peter and tries to stop him
she eventually convinces him and Peter
tries to older hands however before he
is able to do so the evil spirit throws
him off the roof blood splatters
everywhere shocking the people who
witnessed the incident at night one of
Peter's friends Danny is mourning his
death while her mother tries to console
the traumatized girl somewhere else we
see father Benedict and the nun making
love against the rules of the church at
least she's of age that's a win for any
church suddenly they hear a noise nearby
and go out to investigate to their shock
they are welcomed by Blood marks all
around the church the next day Dany is
bullied by one of her friends at church
she tries to defend herself which causes
the bully to be attacked by a strange
Force just when everyone is wondering
what happened the girl notices a
devil-like creature standing behind
Danny's mom later at night all the girls
are possessed by an evil spirit the nun
trying to find a way out of this reads a
book about the devil she concludes that
they are being attacked by a devil named
mashit my don't stank she tries to
convey the message to the father but at
the same time Peter's Spirit arrives and
informs them that the devil is someone
they know the father and the nun believe
that the evil spirit is inside Dany so
they decide to perform an exorcism on
her before it's too late when they try
to do so Danny's mom intervenes and
takes her away from them later the
father realizes that the devil has been
inside dany's Mom all along in the next
scene Danny's mom enters the girl's
living quarters and tortures every girl
the father and the nun run to the room
and notice Danny's mouth is closed with
stitches soon the children under the
influence of the devil start attacking
them the father and the nun try to
defend themselves by carrying a sword
and reluctantly kill some of the
children but they come back to life and
brutally kill the father meanwhile
Danny's mom climbs to the rooftop and is
ready to throw herself off the nun tries
to stop her from taking her life but
Danny's mother grabs her and both fall
down to their Doom Danny's mother passes
away but the nun is somehow still alive
it is then revealed that the evil spirit
has possessed the none now Danny's mom
has passed the devil own the scene
shifts back to the theater where the
father sits terrified the projectionist
appears behind him strikes him hard and
kills him the next story is about a
woman named Helen who also enters the
theater in her movie she is inside a
hospital with her sons who continuously
mock her Helen takes a look around the
hospital and finds everything strange
given her degrading mental health later
when she meets with the doctor she tries
to explain the strange environment
around her but is interrupted by an
emergency call from the doctor's
assistant the doctor then urges Helen to
meet him the next day after leaving the
room unwillingly Helen starts panicking
upon not seeing her sons around she
looks for them everywhere while asking
the staff but no one seems to give her
the attention she needs frustrated Helen
takes out a pistol from her bag and
tries to shoot herself seconds before
she pulls the trigger she hears her
son's voice outside and follows it she
notices the Shadows of the doctor and
her sons on the other side of the door
they are talking about her ill condition
and how the only solution to help her
would be to get her to commit the unsafe
able they also mentioned that they have
provided her with a gun that has one
bullet for this exact purpose when the
doctor says that Helen is listening to
their conversation she approaches them
and shoots the doctor right into his
head following that she drags her sons
away from the place to take them home
the scene then shifts to the theater
where Helen finds a gun inside her bag
once again her story ends as we hear a
gunshot indicating that she finally did
the deed or maybe she shot that dirty
projectionist the last story is about a
young boy named Riley he is listening to
music while walking down a street at
night when he notices the theater
unaware of the horror inside he goes in
and watches a movie about himself in the
movie he is a famous penis a penis and
is playing the piano in front of a huge
crowd his proud parents are in the
audience enjoying their son's show after
the performance the family is in their
car when a stranger emerges from the
back seat and holds Riley at gunpoint he
orders the parents to get out of the car
and kneel down when Riley's father
retaliates the kidnapper shoots him and
his mother Riley tries to run away but
he is also shot by the kidnapper in the
next scene we see Riley waking up inside
a hospital traumatized by what happened
to his parents the doctor avoids any
questions he asks about his parents
which annoys the kid while in the
hospital Riley Witnesses bizarre things
going on around him a few hours later he
is visited by the kidnapper who pretends
to be his family just as he is about to
kill the boy a nursery arrives and asks
him to come back the next day later
Riley meets another patient named Casey
and as they chat we get to know that
they can see dead people there's Bruce
Willis right over there the next day
Riley has a vision of his mother asking
him to come get her she wants her son to
die so she could get to be with him in
the afterlife Casey intervenes in their
conversation and asks the woman to let
Riley live she tells Riley to stay
strong and not fall for his mother's
words and walks away not long after
Riley's mother kills the girl later that
night the kidnapper comes to Riley again
and attempts to kill him for the third
time the kid somehow manages to get away
and hide inside one of the morgue
containers with Casey's corpse he only
gets out of the container after several
minutes thinking that he is safe but as
it turns out the kidnapper is still
looking for him all of a sudden Riley
gets another vision of his mother asking
him to give up simultaneously Casey
suggests he fight back and live Riley
listens to Casey and stabs the kidnapper
with a stick right through his neck to
kill him when everything ends Riley is
being escorted to his room when the dead
kidnapper yet again appears in front of
him the scene then shifts to the theater
where Riley sits scared of what he just
saw the projectionist comes to him and
asks him to run if he wants to save his
life he also reveals that all the
previous participants are dead in the
final scene the projectionist places
Riley's tape on a shelf as the camera
zooms out we see the Shelf contains a
large number of such boxes
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching